it's interesting because you've you've
done so many different kinds of roles I
think that's that's difficult you
haven't allowed yourself to be penned
and you had a lot of success not so long
ago in Shrek 2 right doing the The Voice
people love this character Puss in Boots
people loved you as put some big you've
been able to you know play it play
around a little bit now was that fun
doing that that part yeah it was fun he
was fine it was fun actually they call
me after 16 years in America just to use
my voice when I arrived to this country
without even speaking the language but I
hate the character man everybody ever
since I play him the women used to come
to me and say we'll have you Enzo
Antonia no they come and say we love
your pussycat and did you now I was told
that you you thought Shrek 2 was very
emotional when you finally saw it that
you were moved by it is that true yeah I
know where you're going yes when we were
present in the movie in Cannes in
Festival I never saw the movie before I
saw I saw you there if you can stream
festival is a festival very very tough
with practically the whole entire
intellectuality from Europe concentrate
in the Palais you know where they put
the movies and now they can be very
cynical yeah oh yes it can be mean
really mean and but the people applauded
the movie like 15 times and and at the
end of the movie with the music and
everything you know I just look at you I
was sit down over here Cameron Diaz was
here and Justin Timberlake was on the
other side and I just you know I'm
getting a demotion and I just look at
adjusting and Justin was the same than
me so just he was tearing up too yeah so
he put the hang we both hold hands there
you can get away with that you know I
held his hand was seen holding his hand
weeping I get in trouble until it was
revealed that I was Orgazmo
okay now I wanna talk about this movie
take the lead because this is this is
interesting you you know
you surprised me you really seem like
you you're dancing the tango you're very
good in this film and not that I doubt
that you're you're not capable of doing
these things but you know you sort of
seem like a pro is that is that true I
know I'm an actor and I don't dance
really I just learned the choreography
so say I'm not a sore fighter I am NOT a
horse rider and everything that I have
done in my life from movies is just
because I am pretending just try to make
believe
but with the lighting situation is
saying is actually more difficult than
those things that I said before you know
English or on stuff like that
I was dancing with a world champion of
tango with 24 years old and somebody it
looks like somebody just placard on the
wall I mean she was very energetic and
it was difficult but it just came out
beautifully like I'm a dancer I'm not
and this is this is based on a true
story which is nice it's based on a true
story and we are just is based on the
story of Pierre du Lane guilt Elaine is
a man whose world champion also of
ballroom dancing and he went to public
schools and here in New York and at the
beginnings and experiment he picked
eight kids trouble kids
I mean start teaching them ballroom
dancing and now he got 9,000 kids all
around the United States and 34
professors and it seems to be working
it's beautiful it's a it's inspirational
fantastic and unexpected in the same way
because you don't expect that from
ballroom dancing no we have a clip here
from take the lead anything we need to
know for this well actually what I
intend to demonstrate in this clip is
that because the kids are you know
thinking that ballroom dancing is not
for them you know there are rappers
they're into hip-hop in another type of
music and then he just decided this to
go with this girl there and show them a
tango and show them that ballroom
dancing can be strong can be sexy and
can be like you're gonna seize right the
second takeaway
you can't do that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that you're you said it you're not
advancing you say that you're just
acting but you you have through your
acting it seems like you already you've
you've you can do it you've put it off
what's the secret you just want to be
bad you if you want to be a world
champion which is not gonna be an easy
thing but if you want to just dance
anybody can do it you can do it
you know I am play I will assure you
that I could not do it you can you're
gonna come over here
[Applause]
all right back off you guys it worked
out but that's not me okay well I mean
we have to go with them you you're gonna
start with two quick steps ahead I'm
starting with your left leg left leg is
found open all right
just acting on the side slope that time
so all you do is one two three go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I guess butcher the
very nice you can vote off what's with
the hips
what's all that going on there how can
you do that I gotta get working on that
thing right there
we just gotta look at each other without
hip clearance that it looks like we are
gonna do Brokeback Mountain too I just
tore nine things I didn't know I had
take the lead opens next Friday next
weekend on Tony will be hosting Starnet
live with musical guest mary j blige
watch that show
[Applause]